we just want to bring in some breaking
news from Ukraine where a number of
people have been killed in shelling
which has hit a bus and a cultural
center their skies Katie stallard is in
done yet for us now so Katie what's
happened yeah this happen around an
error and a half ago no we've just
witnessed some with what is being taken
away from here if we show you a bit
around this scene this is one of the
cars which was hit we've just seen a
man's body being taken out of this car
he was killed as he sat in the passenger
seat and Kathy a bus driving away now
actually with all five bodies valishia
across like this the green bus has just
collected the five bodies from this
scene and is taking them to the morgue
in Donetsk this is outside the hotel the
hotel Europe in very central Donetsk we
are in the car park immediately outside
the hotel we're told that people were
queuing here for humanitarian aid when
this shell struck and I can see from the
faces of the people here ho hi shocking
this is as I stress this is the city
center we're told that people were
queuing here for humanitarian aid when
two shells it in quick succession this
van again you can see and windows blown
out there is trapnell damage to various
of the buildings around here beyond it I
mean you can see the force of the blast
has taken the tops off these trees
before bodies that we saw earlier word
immediately behind this white van so
this seems to be one of the main points
of impact here from everything that we
can see from the bodies that we have
seen being taken away they were wearing
civilian clothes two of them look to be
middle-aged women the other three were
men there was nothing to indicate that
they were wearing any sort of military
gear that there were any form of
combatants so as I say as best as we can
tell these were five civilians killed
here queuing for aid in central Donetsk
Katie salad thank you